hello they reject nation I'm Greg Alba
and I'm from struggling nation man why
are you there's such a delayed reaction
because I wanted I thought you were
gonna say more
speaking of reactions hashtag struggle
nation go check out their YouTube
channel we have checked it out already
what are you guys that 420,000 subscribe
Bob hit 420 great number it really is on
the river I don't know how I get it so
yeah it really has all the fame and
we're gonna watch this video from
corridor crew oh yeah FX artists react
to bad and great CGI number 11 I met
these guys actor yeah the last time you
were here we did a reaction or other
videos and then I met most of them at an
event days very very kind people then if
you like yeah it's not a reaction so yes
awesome did a great dude's smooth
transition to this one sure has short
film on his channel Dead by Dawn it's an
evil dead short horror film we shot it
in one night two hundred dollar budget
definitely go check it out seriously I
really enjoyed it a lot if you like
horror like gory stuff like even dead I
think you'll really enjoy this I did a
reaction to it for his channel was
definitely surprised by some stuff that
went down in that it's great effects as
well speaking of effects based artists
yes smooth transition thank you thank
you special guests surprise whoa so
there's the things that you consider
when you're shooting I met them and the
gym and I'm am screening oh really yeah
curious know what they thought yeah
welcome back to another episode of VFX
artists reacts
today we are gonna watch some really
cool clips have you got an extra special
guest surprise now
I'm solo a Star Wars story and there's
something really interesting about the
sequence one is like it's a pretty sweet
train heist sequence and all that but it
ends in a very climactic await here
let's just watch it what's actually cool
about this shot is that everything is
fake except for the explosion wait this
is real it was actually inspired by our
good friend Gavin from the slow mo guys
so what they did was they actually took
a phantom camera they 3d printed the
mountain and putting in a giant fish
tank and they shot it something like 45
different times and from different
angles so what you're seeing are real
air bubbles within water wrapping around
the edges of the mountain so oh holy
because it is flawless simulation oh
love it they use real elements that is
salty waterfall right speaking of using
real elements there's a robot in this
movie that was basically a real robot
held on set it's the same thing they did
on Game of Thrones but they would have
like this crazy-looking skeleton dude
with like a green screen leg and they
would just remove the leg here's the
thing about all of this no they go
through all the trouble erasing out all
of the internals and they're like we're
gonna keep all of the actual costume
bits in and then we remove the green
screen then we fill in all the internal
bits and then we replace the entire
costumes actually here then combining
real and CG together if you just render
it all in CG and have it work together
the lighting and the shadows it might
just be faster plus it probably ends up
looking better with the actual like not
house entertainment not stuff you can
see the biggest changes are the actual
reflections of the sky on the machine
itself she could have just been wearing
a mocap suit rather than the actual
robotic suit but it does put her one in
a better mindset for acting like a robot
and to the best lighting reference you
can possibly have so this is a very high
budget version of very how does it come
shot yeah
you got some poppy seed in your no
[Music]
example of a lot of great reference
sunset but ultimately I guess replacing
the CG model and so another robot that
also looks great what was done very
practically this is a robot from my own
mother
oh right yes my new teleportation spell
everybody here who has seen my mother
sorry I do see you so abruptly am I in
the VFX artists react if you are right
now you are and for those of you who
don't know this is grants Victoria the
director of my mother way too many times
yeah but I am very happy to comment on
anything that you need me to talk about
so the robot my mother you guys put
together a suit that is it's our one of
the best practical robots have ever seen
nice you also have some CG robot shots
yeah it's almost the secret of the film
because we really wanted to celebrate
practical effects when we were making
this a lot when you're making a little
budget film there are a bunch of things
with the script cold for that we
couldn't let the suit do wait how many
suits did you have one and see if you
can tell what CJ and what's real mother
chillin babies in the film get born in
24 hours it's an easy bag of the baby so
that real baby was interacting with that
robot there so maybe the hands are quite
cool and they were like that holding CG
CG robot the baby can't get games to act
it's triggered ok don't get bad for that
oh no baby
oh yeah that looks really big somehow
it's moving like the slight jiggles and
it's hard to do that right sequence of
shots it's all real okay that was pretty
big real it was a close-up on the wrist
you get the really nice detail in the
highlights and scratches and see what's
interesting is that shot is completely
real but another shot that's equally
tight and close and he's actually they
do really yeah credit to the VFX guys of
fin they don't the CG mother after we
made the real mother so it's all that
okay why would you choose to have the
baby holding on to a CG hand rather than
a practical in this instance we've got a
better performance from the baby when
the baby was interacting with a real
mother being a robot that's completely
real it was changeable initially we had
the baby interacting with the robot with
the head off so like she understood that
like the really sweet man that was
playing my little Luke Walker was inside
this bit of costume and eventually we
put they had on that's cool the shot
where the baby gets put on the floor and
you see mother's feet that's actually CJ
I actually thought that was real because
they use interacting yet not that CJ
that ShotSpotter
the things were gonna sit side by side
impressive equally at the whole film
the bomb was sitting really high it was
basically realism like it's gotta look
real and the VFX guys thought that well
the original plan on stuff like this
word that like let's have the real suit
and then just replace the hands like
let's have their hands go faster oh yeah
but it actually proved to be more
difficult to get those arms to feel like
they were locked to the body than it was
to just completely replace mother and
that was something that we felt
increasingly confident doing
[Music]
this is like the last day of second-unit
photography and so there was nothing to
lose somewhere and so he was just gonna
do within the clothes that he was
wearing but the VFX guys were like it's
all black like in a dark environment we
can't see you and then Luke being the
exhibitionist that he is is like skin
that's crazy how did you make the real
suit look so CG it's ultimately about
hiding the fact that there's a person in
there right and you want the audience to
suspend disbelief there's a bunch of
tricks that we're doing to be able to do
that mother's head is actually sitting a
couple of inches of piles Luke's head
and that allows you to create these sort
of cavities like in around their neck
line oh there's no way to hide a person
that was that took like six months like
to get worked out like what exactly
mother look like I knew I always wanted
to look like a real robot reminds me
like the eventual evolution of the
toilet I want to see Clint in a motor
camp
how much more do you think it would make
having a practical versus a CG suit
what exactly are you seeing in the
performance that changes part of it is
like everybody actually being on the
same page and sharing the same reality
and that's like within the confines of
the things that's such a good point
sharing the same reality
can you describe to us what we're seeing
with this weird like island all about
this this blue screen suit that you've
developed yeah it kind of looks like wow
this is a really high-end film with the
fancy blue version of mother that they
using for CJ but this is actually a
black fine suit that whether built
before they built the real suit as a
test case when you still have the
citizen around exactly and we just got a
couple of cans of blue spray paint and
we just spray painted it blue that's it
it's so important because when you've
got that interaction from an actor like
with what's ultimately going to become a
CG thing you need to terrain to sort of
map down I think I'm seeing too much and
I couldn't really see too much of the
original Beach all of the outside world
is filmed on the same Beach like so when
Clara reaches the beach that's the same
place where the bunker door is right but
we use CG to kind of create the variety
and the landscapes that make it feel
like you've covered a greater terrain I
think this movie is really showcasing a
pretty big turning point in visual
effects where you guys had a budget but
it's not a huge budget dad I know
exactly what you mean like in a Netflix
both the film at Sundance it was made
completely independently it was made in
Australia and we never had enough money
but we were working with the effects
companies that were really skilled
really passionate and really wanting to
prove them couldn't if you want to kind
of get in touch with you
it's what's best to do that Instagram at
Brands bhadori
great and you owe me a teleport you back
to Australia that would be super
convenient it is a long fly all right
here we go
all right Clint get back over here
oh yeah dude patreon all right atrium
movie Space Jam oh my god I did not
realize they're gonna come right Jackson
Michael Jordan this is at the beginning
of motion tracking like camera tracking
like the movies before that we're still
doing it manually and they ended up kind
of developing their own software to do
all the camera tracking they filmed all
of Michael Jackson Jordan yeah they shot
any other people on a green-screen stage
with red tracking markers and then they
recreated the entire court digitally Wow
this is the first time I remember seeing
Looney Tunes with like proper shading as
opposed to just a shading the hand-drawn
2d drawings of each of the Looney Tunes
characters there's just one past
flatlining right then they do a whole
passive like any shading and they would
be able to adjust that and blur it out
we're necessary if they need it to
adjust on the amount of directional
lighting on them it's pretty sweet oh
how do you think the cartoon character
passes a basketball to a real-life
person like Michael Jackson dang it
Michael Jordan is maybe using a pretend
basketball I think it's one of the first
photo scans oh really
they took hundreds of photos of this
basketball from every possible angle
angry created it in 3d anytime the
cartoon characters are dribbling around
they're dribbling a 3d rendered ball and
they made it look as close to the real
ball that Michael Jackson was using on
set you guys have a movie with some
sweet visual effects please leave a
comment down below we read them all we
actually have a really fun time going
through all
so please keep it up let's thanking from
1998 to the Year 2019 here we've seen
the tip not yet this action alright so
we just had a chance to see Jim and I
man in theatres all of us in 3d at 120
frames per second oh really
you say that I actually really enjoyed
the action this movie where you see it
like that it was pretty cool they were
traditional real based great things to
consider when you're shooting little bro
the angry dug down into it when you're
watching something that's 4k at 120
frames per second in 3d you can tell
when the actors are wearing makeup
did any actors wear makeup I mean this
subtle makeup here and there the
traditional makeup is not present in
this movie but here's the thing some
fight scenes right you can see every
little bit of motion you can tell when
it's sudden man it's gonna throw with
their face before the hand connects I
don't turn your fans for stuff oh right
I don't see that at 24
so these fight scenes they need to
actually go in and reanimate them so
this only throws a punch the face
doesn't move until the hand is pushing
the face but you know what we're
digressing guys what the heck who is
that if you don't know Smith let's talk
a little bit about some of the
technology they had to do in Gemini man
to get him to look real you know I like
talking about how for it's got a stretch
oh yeah I pour a stretch in Gemini man
they didn't just take a texture with
pores and like you got how to stretch
they took the model and they had a
procedural generation of pores on the
face you look at the back your hand
right and you go like this you'll see
very fine wrinkles and that's the
platelets of your skin stacking up on
top of each other and so the procedural
pours and the procedural platelets let
them have the wrinkles follow the
appropriate cracks and crevices to get
exactly perfect the micro wrinkles for
the spirit what a digital do all the
effects yes
what other effects company yeah anyways
shush so wrinkles is important to get
right but skin tone is important to get
right to so once again in CG graphics
you might just throw texture on there
right not in this movie they had melanin
simulation what if you be like this the
blood gets pushed out of the parts of
your skin that gets square
or push back into it this is the kind of
stuff you have to think about when you
do the human face it is not easy and you
want me to blow your minds even further
the shots with jhemini man
they are motion capturing its entire
body and they rendered the entire body
as a digital replacement only problem I
had with this movie was the motion of a
lot of different things
saying the dirt bike so when things
break the rules of gravity like in this
case the dirt bikes very subtle but we
can all tell it doesn't feel right
motion is pretty much the hardest thing
to get right that is your darkness you
have to walk through this see your end
is please there is no muscle going from
your nose no do you like to pull it
straight up not very much
that's not reality this one whose bottom
lip is putting his top lip up it looks
correct yeah there's another thing that
there's listening and it's kind of a
byproduct of morph targets and emotion
tracking but it's not just joining it
anytime in the CG face it looks fake
take a look at that upper lip and watch
it slide up on its own because there's
no muscle there and subconsciously you
know it anytime CG face doesn't it you
really can't tell effect it isn't that
what we saw the deep safety better with
Princess Leia whoa terms well we
actually found that a really really
really good Will Smith impersonator
super nice guy take a look at it I think
it's one of the best most myth need face
you never see Tom Casey things are huge
evening commute affecting the technology
and
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
try to catch the high frame rate
screening of it I do I do highly
recommend it absolutely but I have an
experience you gotta go see it and you
know so this is really handy especially
[Music]
it's okay war master 236 Lensky snack
cube
anymore
I love how they edited this whole video
yeah they've have a lot more fun with
the way they edit now yeah I don't know
who their editor is but the way they do
it they mess around a lot more I thought
that was a total blast dude I got Will
Smith - actually I do that the real Will
Smith I was looking because I'm like
wait a minute is that hell that's that's
- that's a little too good
especially the ax man I heard the voice
I was like that's not that difficult do
Will Smith voice I can't do it of course
but like that's a little too on the nose
yeah I think that's actually him that
was that was oh but that I had me a
mother it was a mother I am your I am
your mother I am mother in it they were
talking about the importance of using
practical effects which I really
appreciated me as he was talking about
how everyone's on the same board of
reality at that point which I actually
never thought of it like that because I
imagine that what you're doing like
these big green screen movies that it
gets to this point where everyone is
having to just only use their
imagination yeah yeah but everyone could
be imagining something different and
then wouldn't you got a practical
environment they're all reacting and
using the same type of module so that
way they are all on the same page which
I thought was cool and I think the best
use of visual effects of what we've
covered a lot here we're talking about
the droid from solo a Star Wars story or
with I am mother when you combine it
with practical
faxing use digital touch-ups but I found
funny with the Droid and a soloist our
sort of inner point at is that they
practically end up just doing a complete
procedure recreation of the same it's
kind of pointless at the end in the end
yeah it's like this is an argument to me
is like one you get a better performance
out of the actress because she's able to
embody and walk around and enjoy it out
yeah but in terms of VFX Department
you're practically making a whole new
droid outfit so is it even really worth
it in the end to do that it's like
giving Mark Ruffalo some Hulk outfits
but you're just gonna CGI in today so I
even put on a Hulk outfit in that case
you know that's pretty funny to me yeah
what were they saying about like the
slow mo guys over how they blew up that
section so they they put the mountain in
like a fish tank and then blew it up in
the water to get that real bubble Wow
that blew my mind
did they really get inspired by a
YouTube channel I think they did YouTube
channel is a very inspirational for what
I hear I can't wait to see the reaction
movie you know what if there's not one
already out there will be one soon who
were plays at your local theater through
fathom events du Bois well that moat it
and yeah what's the best way to watch
endgame watch Drew and Greg watch
endgame in the theaters live commentary
big faces MMS beside we gotta be
respectful to the movie oh yeah tell me
do it you know it cheer what the Hammers
caught in it that's about it
[Music]
you see Gemini man you know now you do
you're missing out so uh what is the
edge of the third there's been a little
busy but I'm definitely going this week
to go see it yeah I mean if you're a
Gemini man review I still recommended it
because he summed it up best here in the
corridor guys of that as a movie there's
criticisms as an experience it's well
worth it because I was at the same
screening as them was a three-d hundred
twenty frames per second man and the
action scenes in the film are undeniably
beautiful like they are gorgeous and
it's only like a third of the movie that
are action scenes but when they're there
I'm like really dude I don't know how
the movie would play at home but I think
on that type of viewing level it is
perfect so I completely agree with them
there and with the Will Smith face there
are times in the movie where it looks
completely flawless I mean just even
looking here really now looks a hundred
percent real yeah there are shots in the
daylight especially weirdly towards the
end of the movie like the very last few
minutes of the movie where are you they
have a close-up on his face and everyone
just started laughing cuz it just looks
so uncanny it look contorted yeah it
looked very fake that's it's just in
what they point out about the the top
upper lip thing now I'm gonna just look
out for ya I've never looked at that
they kind of ruined it for me cuz I'm
gonna be good point it out now I'm just
gonna be looking at their lips the whole
time I watch a movie right fake fake I
mean is that true your lip doesn't move
I guess it doesn't I've never paid
attention to him I guess it's a thing I
mean they would know I'm ever just like
say a whole bunch of stuff look at look
at my lip did it move didn't move
doesn't move do the next two minutes on
camera I mean I'll give it to them on
solo a Star Wars story she's like I
don't even remember that moment and I
know you haven't seen a lot of people
did it see what's the one actually
wanted to see it though well it's
alright oh that's what I keep hearing
but one thing I'll give it though is
like the way I look so and visually hmm
it's still very impressive on that scale
and then one thing that I think corridor
crew consistently does I told this to
them like why I love their channel there
are things I'll take for granted
constantly when I watch these big-budget
movies or at the effects-heavy films
because a lot of times it's just like
things that last like a second
shot towards a minute and a movie know
that I'll just completely forget about
or I won't take the time to register
this is how much work it took to put
into this one little moment in the film
and these guys are so good at reminding
me of even the films that are quote
unquote like yeah like something that
isn't well-received like soloist star
war story yeah I mean you break down
certain elements like what they have
done here I go oh wait there's a lot to
appreciate in that movie in and of
itself even would Gemini man like yeah I
think what they said about movie
criticisms versus experience is a great
way to put it for a lot of these films
they're so good at what they do they can
pick out everything and make you have
like a new appreciation for even back
when we solved that ultraviolet one that
they did they were pointing out things
that and I hated the movie and I don't
know why I hated the movie but they
pointed out things so that I knew why I
hate it I'm like yeah that didn't work
for me at all and I'm like oh yeah
that's why but they're so good at
picking out everything because this is
what they do you see everything in a
whole new light sure they might have
ruined up a little thing for me
hopefully they didn't oh really didn't
but you know I like what they do I like
I do very impressive stuff alright guys
we've ever done so already subscribe to
Korra crew
subscribe to struggle Nation check out
their short film subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification about
again notify would ever got a YouTube
video up and I'm really hungry
drew has been here for two hours way
longer than anyone should be here make
me a sandwich
wait go pick up some bread